hello America I'm Greg this is a Arielle
yeah I usually I always forget to tell
the guests to say their name every that
rene REO who you might have seen on
Amber's channel before Amber's been on
this channel and she has her own [ __ ] as
well on YouTube Renee are real Instagram
Renee REO Twitter today REO all of it
all of it Renee are do I'm on all them
all the time all the time what do you
post pictures videos videos yeah
modeling photos on there right I do I
have modeling photos on me yeah oh yeah
I'm on there all the time I know I know
anyway they think the one is a channel
channel that does challenge videos Renee
has never done a try not to laugh video
and I said hey Renee let's do it try not
to laugh since those are the best most
fun-filled content the real rejects have
and I said okay let's do it
there's so much discussion to be made
like to shout out the first person
requests to this cuz he makes me
interactive with the audience you know
it's like whoa he's relatable yeah talks
to the people that's so cool of you man
friendship have friendship Trevor
munchies
he's the one who requested challenge
number four so did a couple other people
Trevor munchies I know nothing about
munchies I've never smoked a dab in my
life it was my face right there oh wow
and he kind of likes me I think
don't laugh just don't laugh or smile
random
it's cancer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's your lucky day I will now turn
the side and see this great sight why
the bush is not burnt when the Lord saw
that he turned aside to see God called
him to him out of the midst of the bush
and said Moses they're moving in Herod's
they do move inherent really that's the
big teardrop our line kind of random
isn't it I mean this I kind of like
walking out over the herd and say [ __ ]
they do eat their own [ __ ]
oh my god it's important not sure much
affection after mating with the teenage
porn star they may follow you home and
search for your trash it's important to
put them in their place right from the
get-go yeah
clean yourself up you smack that was too
greedy
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh anyway no comeback a cheeky one wait
okay hello you people know a lot about
trucks
[Music]
[Music]
our church what was that cult at the end
there's my face right there oh wow he
kind of likes me I think
how was your first trying to laugh
challenge I fail you fail instantly
first one you failed badly Renae I can't
with when people hurt themselves but I'm
so bad but I love my suicide like the
walls done like no one video of the girl
that little girl that hits the closet
when she's doing the runway and then
have you ever seen that yeah you guys
know which one that kills me every time
still what was the one that you
immediately lost you know I find these
like kind of easy like something I just
end up laughing but I was like this one
I'm really gonna do my best and not like
really laughs I noticed the more I tried
containing it my I started to tear up
actually I started crying feel good I
needed a good cry it's been a little
stressful lately
good release laugh challenges illustrate
just came out there I think we found
different ones funnier well maybe we
have two different senses of humor don't
mean it but that's that's how you know
it's a good trend because it's for
everyone there were ones I really didn't
find funny at all but there was some
that I could not not laugh you should do
one of these with the guy you're dating
I should yeah really she finds funny
yeah it'll be video and he'll be
watching I'll pick this
really no don't wait up you ever happen
is they get to know your significant
other I think they had the Nostalgia
Critic video or the Jurassic Park
restarts the well oh and I didn't notice
when they were showing that was like is
he crying yes I love okay I know what
they were going to do with that scene
from Jurassic Park and it's like man I
love that movie but I love that guy why
is it emotional for you right I know I
totally get what you mean the Barney one
with the whisper song which is my future
wedding song Oh creepy it's not creepy
I feel like Barney should sing that song
the children know learning a lot about
you today yeah this is my true colors no
sarcasm here today
no satire image no I think Barney should
sing whisper I think he should sit is
sing uh what's the what's that song
called run by David Banner is that it's
called I'm not sure drip sweat drips
drip sweat I feel that video should be
in like the try not to cringe challenge
oh yeah that was hard
that completely threw me off Garza oh oh
oh and then I suggest the more clips
went on it just got very uncomfortable
know that it didn't that it did not it
did I'm a fan you're comfortable that's
the voice you do pooted my name's ray oh
yeah this guy this is why you won't do
stand-up
I felt bad room I couldn't laugh you
guys so like old [ __ ] attacks for the
first time yesterday
I was waiting for him to come back at
the heckler ya know we're like that's
we're gonna laugh at it feel good laugh
it was like no we're just laughing at
this poor guy oh I wonder if there's any
more footage to that where he does like
yeah ruin that heckler I love watching
comics ruin hecklers Oh sane
except when I'm the heckler oh man this
is I cry I cry long cry I cry I think we
all cry a lot you know what you should
do instead of cry get angry I was gonna
say laugh therapy like that one woman
laughs yoga another cringe yeah that's
called uh the most this is strongest
form of like repression I've ever seen
yeah we get through it by laughing at
yourself about it Oh with that one dude
who like [ __ ] up his kitchen at the
end what [ __ ] but like honestly if your
kitchens that weak man it's probably
better to happen now than later I don't
know if it's because it's that he kind
of got on top and just pulled it down
with all his strength
I mean how strong is he that shouldn't
be a thing in any kitchen I mean I know
I'm strong enough to rip apart my
kitchen yeah Danny I mean like you're
sane but not everyone is you know yes
yeah everyone's like us are just like
yeah you're strong strong you have sue
for the industry yeah obviously so you
can watch anything ones videos and you
can subscribe to the real rejects hey
Renee hey Renee do people do that a lot
of you hey hey Renee
hey Renee and what sort of rhymes yeah
it does Ryan good job thanks I'm Renee
Uriel is on Instagram Twitter not
snapchat [ __ ] snapchat and YouTube as
well you should go follow her on her
social media please tell her the real
rejects sent you show no if you say that
and you know cuz I'm trying to make this
worth your time to be here so if you go
follow her she'll feel like oh that's
how I promote shamelessly